harsh reality you might have to move
poor people don't have a voice
same here though right black mirror
fantasy is a reality now it's one of the
least free countries in the world one
camera for every seven citizens now
how do we compete with that they really
got it going on there and we're
hurting here somalia level poverty in
some of these areas do you want to live
under an authoritarian dictatorship that
tracks your every movement
i don't think china will be the top dog
why this is what the media won't tell
you
it's amazing so beautiful look at these
palms
let's go this way yeah sure i'm still
like being culture shocked
to be honest and you've been back two
years two and a half years two and a
half years
me too okay i'm here with matt thai
lao y86 on youtube one of the coolest
channels i've come across
that's yours no
specializes in china yes so if you're
interested in china
and also china from someone that lived
there
spoke the language married a child's
chinese woman
moved back to the states has all sorts
of interesting takes
on china and the us this is your guy i'm
gonna leave the links at the end
but i got one big question for this
video yeah and it's something that is
quite popular online
sure you know the us as a super power
is declining china is rising sure
this is you know eventually china will
be the biggest economy yeah
and not too long from now right yeah
and not per capita not per capita
but where are we really at
like from your perspective of living
there for me i think like
you know i i've been to china i know the
average chinese person does not live as
well as the average american i know
that's like a basic fact for sure
uh but where things are right now at
this very moment in 2021
i'm not exactly sure so that's why i've
got you here
okay so a really interesting take on
this is that
like you said the american empire is on
the decline it's on the downfall right
right
whereas the chinese empire is uplifting
and it's all the chinese government's
uh doing they're able to lift all their
citizens out of poverty
things are getting better and better
every day while we stagnate we have no
public transport to speak of right
in terms of what china is building high
speed rail stuff
actual infrastructure right you look at
those facts
yeah yeah i mean like it's not pretty
right that being said this is this is
what the media won't tell you
right because it doesn't generate clicks
and it's not as romantic right
the media feeds on this idea that
america isn't declined
right when you feed on that idea it
becomes a snowball
so every other media splinter media
group or whatever is going to go with
that with from a different perspective
okay look at this decaying neighborhood
look at this bridge
look at this so look at all the retail
stores that are closing down look at
this empty mall you grew up with
right goes all the way from politics
down to like personal pieces
sure america's decline sure whereas you
look at
chinese media which is state media
anything coming out of china
goes through the state's mouthpiece
right there's only one
mouthpiece in china there is no
competing media
it's not a free country it's one of the
least free countries in the world so
when you have
everything going through the state
mouthpiece propaganda board and
censorship board because that's how it
works
right the only thing you get is it's
literally like 50
alcohol distilled straight up like
absinthe level
propaganda from china okay and people
have to see it like that because
when a country like china blocks their
populace off from social media
through the great firewall completely
censors any any dissenting opinion or
even doesn't actively doesn't want their
populace to join the international stage
by saying the rest of the world hates
us we are chinese let's separate
ourselves that mental block
even that alone is enough to
really change the warped perspective of
not only chinese citizens but then
people
consuming chinese media outside of china
yeah and it's to china's advantage to
want to portray its system as feasible
viable and attractive because it's an
authoritarian system that really shits
on
the human rights of its populace right
right you have to sell it to your
populace
and then you have to sell it to the rest
of the world so there's two battling
not really battling opinions you have
the the western meter american media
that says america's on a decline
then you have the chinese media which
isn't allowed to say anything bad about
china so you have basically
both extremes yes on the opposite end
yeah is this somewhere in the middle
it's kind of somewhere in the middle so
okay if you look at this perspective
like
the coming china threat right i think
the whole america's decline thing is a
whole different thing
like you can look into that yourself you
can see around you are you did you lose
your job
sure you know are you in a worse
situation than you were a little while
ago sure
you can look at that from a realistic
perspective but with china you have to
be there to understand that okay
okay otherwise you're just going to be
consuming state media from china
but what about on the streets say right
now it depends obviously where
sure but you're on the streets you're
looking around the average chinese
person's looking around and they're
seeing their lives getting better right
for the most part yeah i mean for the
most part in terms of
if you're comparing to the 90s where
they didn't have that much money okay
you're maybe driving around in like uh
you know a 2 000
car now right right like things are
obviously and clearly better
than when you were starving right yes
that being said that gray area of where
china was
booming when i was there 2008. all the
way i'd say i would say it
the kind of feeling of positivity
started slowing down around 2013 2014.
so when you would talk to chinese away
from other people they would open they
would speak
for you you
so you're you're getting the inside yeah
like they're not looking you as a total
foreigner
they're respecting you because you spoke
the language exactly
now the problem with that is is that it
went from this gray area where china was
booming and it was doing really well
because
it was still an authoritarian
dictatorship but it allowed its people i
shouldn't say a lot of hate that word
yeah it kind of relinquished some of the
shackles okay the previous systems maybe
under chairman mao right okay
so that kind of that gradual liberalism
was never on paper
but it was kind of just the way things
work to start a company was fairly easy
a lot of the red tape was cut out there
sure it was this gray area that was just
kind of blossoming and booming for these
chinese people and for them that was a
very positive time but
slowly the surveillance state started
catching up right and when xi jinping
took power
instead of being this the liberal you
know dictator that was going to bring
about change that we all hoped
right he turned out to be more of a fan
of chairman mao right
so to consolidate power at that kind of
alarming speed
and to um you know put up all the
cameras there's
one camera for every seven citizens now
right wow it's a dude
in china there's not a town like this
really like there's
like there would be a camera on every
pole yes okay and that's that's
not to uh ensure the safety of everybody
it's also to catch people out i'm sure
the tracking of everybody exactly i mean
there's a social credit system
that black mirror fantasy that people
were having is a reality now
right sort of like 2020 in in the u.s
it feels like a blimp at least in san
francisco it felt like black mirror i
got yeah a little different here
okay okay let me uh let me ask you this
though yeah
the chinese are very good at having long
term thinking planning they're strategic
and it's not a democracy so it's less
messy in the sense that they can get
everyone on board and push forward even
if it's by force
yes right now in the us we're more
divided than ever yeah
right at least that's what it seems and
things aren't moving in any positive
direction politically it seems like
right everything's a battle right so
with their strategy
like how do we compete with that that
that's something that has to be a mental
uh mental conclusion that you have to
make yourself right do you want to and
maybe maybe this is an attractive option
for people but do you want to live under
an authoritarian dictatorship that
tracks your every
movement tells you what you can think
and do dictates where you go to school
what you do in the future
right all for the option
of of having i don't know better
infrastructure
better public transportation things like
that or would you rather make
your own life yours and i think if you
don't if you don't look at it if you
look at it from face value a lot of
people maybe younger people here in the
us
would have would prefer a thing where
okay whatever as long as i can go out
with my friends and get drunk
and like sure whatever eat dinner with
them or do whatever they like to go to
the club or whatever then that's
not not have to worry right no i don't i
don't care right i'm not
as long as i'm not involved in politics
they say right okay
now the thing is when you actually look
at the nitty-gritty of this
you can you can pretend like china's
actually pulled all this stuff up but in
reality they have it
right so if you look at the poverty
alleviation standard right they pulled
800 million people out of poverty
number one who put them there first
right is the principles of the very same
government that's
that's dealing with them now sure and
i'd like to use this example to show you
how this is not working
the poverty standard of the us is 13 000
per year
right the property standard for china is
400 something dollars a year
so you have to understand the difference
here a lot of americans are looking oh
look at this poverty alleviation look at
how well the government's done
let's go down here yeah look at how well
the government's done in china
not knowing that 400 something dollars a
year is not something they could ever
sustain themselves right
okay to be fair life is much cheaper in
china it is but it's not four hundred
dollars a year
in a big city it's what half the price
we're in carlsbad
but if you want if you wanted to have a
lifestyle that was comfortable if you
wanted to eat like cheese
for example you're going to spend a lot
more money in china than you would here
right
but anyway my point is that when you
when the government manipulates figures
like that when you when you make it
an on level playing field and then what
happens is
all of the the kind of small charities
and stuff that we're operating out of
china like a small village programs
those are gone now because the
government says no the poverty's gone
so they shut those things down so the
actual people in need don't get what
they want
right it's just that you don't hear from
those people rural china is a dire place
it's a dire place it's not like the us
right what about say okay i haven't been
there in a long time but like
gary indiana that's not rural but like
just you're you're from upstate new york
i'm from i'm from vermont originally you
go into some of those backwoods towns
they look pretty depressed sure but not
even a comparison no i mean
we're talking about some of these places
that i mean it's dirt roads which is one
thing but sometimes there's no shoes
i've been to villages where the kids
were blind from malnourishment
yeah this is we're talking about somalia
level poverty in some of these areas
like in guizhou
and gansu it's not the same thing right
and i'm not pinpointing like i am
showing i'm talking about extreme
poverty here but
the standard of living amongst a poor
person in china
is much lower than the standard of
living here in the u.s
and yeah you could say oh give them some
time to catch up but that's the problem
is that that wealth wealth inequality is
is growing
in china because the poor people don't
have a voice
or an option to make life better same
here though right
sure in a way yeah like especially with
the pandemic people are getting richer
or poor right
like the wealthy is getting wealthier
that's absolutely true but
but you're starting like the bar is set
higher here it is is that fair to say
the barcelona not only that people still
have access to charity right
the government in china shuts down the
charities that are helping the poor
people because it makes china look bad
it makes china say oh we didn't
alleviate poverty
so you have a state literally getting in
the way of alleviation
while saying simultaneously that they've
already pulled it off right okay
so i thought that your answer would be
along these lines but you
to sum it up you're basically saying you
know as america's let's say losing its
role to some degree
sure and china's increasing its role i
mean what are we looking at and of
course you can't be a futurist but
like it's not even close right now or
it's like
the the scales are starting to tip in
the sense that you know in 20 years we
pick our heads up and we're like whoa
they really got it going on there and
we're we're sort of hurting here
sure um from what you will see
china will continue to portray itself as
a world leader right okay whether that's
the case or not you have to find out
yourself right you have to talk to
people in china yeah yeah which i do
right now that being said if you're
really looking at metrics like
let's say militarily okay china is
wildly behind militarily
yes their navy is bigger than ours right
but if you want to do a dick measuring
competition here
it's not it's not even close right i
don't think that's how it should be but
the usable navy or unusable military in
china is so far behind the us
no conflict is really feasible in the
near future and that's something i like
to tell people is they all get riled up
they either want like
let's go kick their ass or we have the
other people that are like holy [ __ ]
that would be awful like
yeah yeah the realistic situation isn't
where china would be devastating
militarily way behind right in terms of
way behind by catching up catching up
catching up
skill level actual battle experience
zero right
right um catching up technologically yes
absolutely right but that
for me that scenario is unfeasible for
the time being okay
ideologies might be against each other
right but it's not actually going to
lead
to a a battle or a conflict unless
unless the kamehameha china just started
rapidly losing power in china
okay so i know i'm asking you to be a
futurist here but
like where like do do the
does the average american have a serious
concern or a right to be concerned about
you know china being the top dog in the
near future or not
uh yes yes and no number one i don't
think china will be the top dog
why because it's you have to be cool
okay
soft power soft power is so important
around the world
and that no one does soft power like the
us right this is just the reality
whether you like it or not the reality
is america is still the coolest country
in the world
because everyone from around the world
can come here and make something cool
about it that's what makes it cool
right okay you're black culture it's the
coolest culture in the us right in terms
of consumerism right right
all of these different so look at latino
culture yeah latinx culture they the
people can come together and actually
make something of themselves and then
people within the us and outside the us
consume it right
china doesn't do that china doesn't have
soft power exports that people think is
cool you understand
you think they can get it no no i mean
because of chinese
the world doesn't know chinese so well i
mean we're lucky right now that english
is the de facto world language
it wasn't before it won't always be but
sure that's like
definitely in our favor my counterpoint
is democracy is work in favor of
coolness look at korea it's a tiny
country
yeah that nobody cared about and
everybody knows k-pop now
yeah it's not just k-pop it's korean bbq
it's food it's called
cinema it's fashion right yeah that's
infiltrated white america
that's soft power yeah right china
doesn't have stop power you know what
china has to do is claim soft power that
oh korea used to be a part of china
so that's ours right so in in
i hate to use this word ruling the world
or being the superpower
which there always always has been that
battle sure
unfortunately that's the way the world
works yeah it's game of thrones
it is like i used to be against every
bit of uh american foreign policy
yeah and then i realized well if the us
just chills out sure
it's not like um the world gets all
peaceful and great
i mean i'm not for a lot of the us's
foreign policy sure sir
i'm not for war i mean that's what i've
liked especially in the in the last
few years there's been no real
interventions in the middle east that's
sort of nice
i like that it is but i also have seen
enough of the world to understand that
it's dark in many ways yeah and
if one country isn't controlling another
is trying to control
yeah okay so you're saying
soft power is a huge component to that
control it's massive how are you gonna
sell
the young people or the populist outside
of like politics or like grand gestures
of
bridge building or something how are you
gonna sell that to a young populist that
china is cool because
unfortunately chinese people don't
believe china is cool
right i think china is awesome in terms
of a culture in terms of a country yeah
but you can't export those very might
those very uh
on the not on the surface details the
very minute details that you have to
discover yourself within china
you can't export that as a culture so no
one's listening to chinese music
right yeah chinese food is great that's
fantastic and food's a great export but
there's no cohesive chinese food it's
very diverse food group right there's
not like one dish people be like yes
you know that's let's have that right so
in terms of soft power china just
doesn't have it because the chinese
populace consumes
foreign western south korean japanese
media more so than their own
they consume a lot of japanese media yes
yeah i mean anime is massive
right okay if you asked a lot of chinese
people if they liked japan or japanese
realize their
story tough history there yeah yeah
between the countries
but okay there's there is a
you know china's been slammed down for
the last 300 years it was once the world
power
yeah okay now it now has some muscle it
can sure
it can flex and it has every right to do
so right sure
um you just don't like the way it's
doing it i don't i think flexing is fine
to be a global leader would be a dream
for me for china
okay it's it's i mean you're going to
root for the country you spent 10 years
and
i was rooting for china before i went
there yeah but when you see the shift of
how the government
has has changed right and it has changed
drastically
yeah um it's not it's not who you want
to root for anymore and it's not well
it's not what we want to emulate no no
as a country and
i don't think it's in in when many young
people are here talking about how they
they like admire and think that system
is better it's like
tell them to stop using their their uh
instagram and youtube and google search
and see how that goes
right right like just that just that
basic that basic freedom
yeah right which we take for granted or
sure
like you turn the water i don't know if
it's in china but it was happening in
ukraine you turn the water in one day
it's sort of like greenish color
it does happen and you know nobody's
really checking and maybe someone was
paid off
right for a shift to do something where
they could save some money or whatever
it might be
or even can i drink out of the faucet
right yeah i mean you literally will get
bloody diarrhea if you do that in china
but
it's a country that portrays itself as a
first world nation right okay
it's just not what you see and that's
the frustrating thing is when you're in
china it's not what you see
if you go to the city center the cbd of
shanghai yes you will be duped right
you leave there go a couple hours
outside of there and see how largely how
the country operates
it's not what it's not the romantic idea
that it's being portrayed yeah yeah and
to be fair guys we're in carlsbad it's a
pretty affluent
neighborhood san diego if we go
if we go uh 20 miles that way right
yeah it's a different reality for sure
it's a different reality okay but yeah i
mean
you can make those equivalencies right
sure it's just not and i'm not trying to
say china is unbelievably poor but the
soft power
it doesn't work when you see the reality
of the situation and it's not a
an idea that should be romanticized
because because it comes with a lot of
baggage
it comes with surveillance and it comes
with a heavy-handed dictatorship
right so you're thinking america's in a
good place right now
and china is not necessarily a threat to
its
position for quite some time from
executive fair way but from a global
metric i think
america is fine if if people understand
not how good they have it but how many
opportunities they have to make it
better
right gotcha and it's not some psa from
the 90s about like let's
hold hands and like make the world a
better place this concrete actual things
yeah for example what you're doing right
now is being an influencer that's not a
job that existed when i was a kid oh
yeah
but it's something that anyone can
actually do right i have a
350 gopro in my hand right that's in
that's what you're doing to to make a
living right now right yeah
100 there you go me too right that those
opportunities exist i'm not saying go
out there and be an influencer but
open your mind a little bit about how
much there is on the table for you
there's so much just by coming back to
the states my uh
my u.s audience built up yeah and then
u.s ad revenue is different than
say ukrainian ad revenue so i'm making
way more money just by being here
on the ground here and it's just sort of
like a metaphor for everything in the
states i feel like i feel like
there's some guy that has a roofing
business that's probably killing a
plumbing business electric
business pavement business right here
he's got a truck he probably it's a base
level ford f150 he can operate out of it
and operate a business and make money
out of it yeah and one thing i want to
say the opportunities are here where we
are north of san diego
where you and i both grow up grew up not
so much no
and so one harsh reality it's not even
harsh it's just a reality
you might have to move that is that's
actually a great piece you might have to
just like get it like
you know i grew up in a town of 500
people sir what would i do there right
now nothing
i'd have to drive very far or no clue
right but you could go back there and do
something
with i mean yes and now because of the
internet right i mean technically i
could live there
but i don't want it right but that
initial kick is very important for kids
to understand yeah and i wish i did that
earlier like i went to
like new york earlier or so san
francisco earlier that would be
you know i would go to san francisco now
let's not get advice but
don't take me yourself
yeah matt thank you no worries guys
check out his channel
uh as you can see he's very
knowledgeable very interesting character
uh link down below la y86
yeah check out your videos awesome get
on the next one